we hit the body with a tremendous uh
whether it's ultraviolet or just very
powerful light
and then i see the disinfectant where it
knocks it out
in a minute one minute and is there a
way we can do something like that
by injection inside or
or almost a cleaning i think we have
enough of an interview here hope
okay that's enough let's go let's go
uh let's go meet for two seconds okay
thanks i'll see you in a little while
thanks as the great religious teacher
swami vive kamand
once said the question was
when you said we have 15 and they're
going to go to zero how did you come up
with that
walk us through how you decided 15 cases
were going to go to zero
and it's true there was a time when we
had one person
in this country we knew about it we
worked on it but we had one person
it mushroomed to 15 people mushroom the
president of the united states
told the interviewer that the
interviewer would be unable to do as
well on a cognitive test meant to screen
out dementia
you couldn't answer all right what's the
question many of the questions i'd get
you the test i'd like to give it
but i guarantee you that joe biden could
not answer those questions
okay cannot make a brilliant speech
where they say that was such an
incredible elegant speech
if i'm talking about dishwashers sinks
toilets
light bulbs try going and buying a new
faucet
you turn it on no water comes out right
we won't talk about toilets but you know
that's
donald trump sort of laughed off ruth
bader ginsburg's
dying wish that she not be replaced
until a new president has been seated
inaugurated
well i don't know that she said that or
was that written out by adam schiff and
schumer
and pelosi i i would be more inclined to
the second okay you know that came
out of the wind it sounds so beautiful
god gave us grace on november 8 2016
to change the course we were on i think
i've done
more for the black community than any
other president and let's
take a pass on abraham lincoln because
he did
good although it's always questionable
you know in other words the end result
we are free mr president trump even
tried tweeting
that had he not done his corona ride
around the hospital
the media would have said he's wrong not
to do it
i want to see peace say it do it say it
do you want to call them what do you
want to call them give me your name give
me a white surprise
and write presents stand back and stand
by
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania donald
trump
uh had protesters tear gassed
and dispersed with horses to clear the
way
for donald trump to walk to saint john's
church in washington dc and be
photographed
holding up a bible but what has it been
like have you loved the job or is it has
it been worth it because you've been
under so much attack
well it's been mean it's been uh
you've dealt with horrible people like
shifty schiff and
crazy nancy and brian shirt and they
have spikes
look here germany low 9000. here's one
right here united states
you take the number of cases look we're
last meaning we're first lost
but the same vaccine could not work you
take a solid flu vaccine you don't think
that would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona
no probably not donald trump seemingly
talking about chicago and then jumps
right into
afghanistan 58 people were shot this
weekend in chicago 10 died okay let's
get on to the weather how's the weather
they've gotten almost used to it 58
people
so we're pulling out of afghanistan as
you know schools should be open
if you look at children children are
almost and i would almost say
definitely but almost immune from this
disease
donald trump admitting to bob woodward
that
at the time february 7th his belief
about coronavirus was that it was very
serious even airborne
well i think bob really to be honest
with you sure i want you to i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
between you people don't answer don't
talk to me that way you're just uh
you're just a lightweight don't talk to
me that way
don't talk to i'm the president of the
united states no air conditioning in the
summer no heat
during the winter and no electricity
during peak hours let's watch
president trump on television i'm sorry
we won't be able to do it
the wind isn't blowing today darling we
won't be there during
joe biden's time to speak trump would
just talk over him
and insult him number one with bernie
sanders far left on the manifesto we
call it
man that's because you socialize
medicine look hey are you still not
gonna
listen to him you know what i say is
your ass
i don't talk about my ass trump also
tweeting
i won this election by a lot
and almost poetic was the news that at
the time networks called the election
saturday morning donald trump was
golfing that
wisconsin we're leading by a lot
and then at 3
42 in the morning
there was this it was a massive dump
of votes